[Music]
hello i'm linda you and i'm delighted to
host this debate knowledge versus
creativity from the development of a
successful covet vaccine to the
formulation of a new scientific theory
from the composition of a great opera to
the making of an award-winning movie we
prize creativity and celebrate its
products yet in our education system and
in our exams creativity is largely
excised and in working life carrying out
a task accurately and efficiently is the
primary focus are we right to focus on
learning knowledge and experience or
should we give greater emphasis to
creativity in all of its many forms and
encourage new solutions and new ways of
operating
but is creativity only possible when the
hard work of learning the rules has been
achieved more fundamentally
is creativity itself unfathomable and
impossible to teach and limited to those
with exceptional talents
to debate all of this i'm joined by a
lovely expert panel
lisa feldman barrett is a northeastern
university distinguished professor and
among the top 1
most cited scientists in the world for
her revolutionary research in psychology
and neuroscience she is author of the
best-selling books seven and a half
lessons about the brain and how emotions
are made
jesse norman is a politician and
philosopher in his day job he is
financial secretary to the treasury in
his spare time he is a biographer of
adam smith and edmund burke and has
written highly successful and
interesting books on each of these
figures
and sripali patel is director story
storylab a multi-award-winning cambridge
based research institute that
experiments and interrogates narrative
form and function to create powerful and
purposeful films she is director at
eyeline films a bafta award-winning
production company she's also part of a
radical higher education project the new
school of the anthropocene
welcome to all of you
each panelist now has three minutes to
put forward their view their pitch
on
this question that we're all here to
debate today which is are we right to
value knowledge over creativity
lisa feldman barrett
thank you so much and thank you for
including me in this event
um i guess from the perspective of
neuroscience i would say this is an
ill-posed question because
um under the hood
you know in terms of what our brains are
doing uh there's tremendous dependency
on between knowledge and and creativity
so
for example the way your brain works is
it takes what you know and combines it
in novel ways
in order for you to recognize things
that you've never seen before so when
you see a flight of stairs that you've
never encountered before how do you know
that it's a flight of stairs how do you
know how to walk up that flight of
stairs
how do you understand the metaphor of a
social ladder or a you know a a a
hierarchy um that implies um walking you
know climbing um a ladder or stairs
the way that you that you understand
these things is by something called
conceptual combination where your brain
takes bits and pieces of knowledge and
combines them in novel ways um so that's
a form of creativity so basically the
way knowledge manifests itself in your
brain is as creativity
and similarly
uh in order to be creative in the
conventional sense as you pointed out
linda um we need to have knowledge and i
would
you know point people to what i call the
picasso principle which is picasso
before he was able to invent cubism
actually learned the tools and and um
skills as a classical uh
painter consider his blue period for
example the only way that he was able to
um
you know invent discover creatively
emerge um
uh creatively um a form uh
a new school of painting is because he
was he had a lot of knowledge um being
classically trained i guess the final
thing i will say is that
creativity the way it's defined in is
the use of imagination
to create original ideas so it's
basically
imagination the basis of imagination is
what we know this this is what
neuroscience tells us the things that we
imagine are just creative combinations
of the things we already know and
creativity is a skill that is that is
learnable
um
and that's actually skills that are
learnable are actually called procedural
knowledge in in psychology and in
neuroscience so i would say
you know the
there's an interesting discussion here
to be had but i think
you know opposing these or you know
comparing these or setting them up as in
opposition to each other i think is
um at least from a scientific
perspective not the not the way that i
would phrase the question
thank you very much um
jesse norman same question to you are we
right to value knowledge over creativity
uh of course i agree with lisa that the
question is ill-posed because
there is no
direct conflict between the idea of
creativity and knowledge but i would go
further to say that
it it should be obvious on reflection
that uh
not only does the picasso principle
apply but they really
we can tell ourselves a story and it may
be morally uplifting it may be the
result of a romantic
uh revolution in our thinking in the
early 18th century where we started to
privilege the idea of the lone and
solitary genius on a mountaintop uh
viewing the heavens uh but of course
there really is
very very little blank slate as you
might say creativity and
a lot of the examples that you might
think of as blank slate creativity come
really from two things one is
that the person who is regarded as the
great creative genius
is and of course it is often a story
about individual achievement whereas
much creativity is a story about
collective achievement um
uh is is is something that comes because
the person has just slightly ahead of a
peer group and of course it's famously
true that genius has no peer direct peer
group to assess its uh its um
effects and its impact um but there's
another thing going on here i think
which is that of course genuine
creativity requires not just practice
and expertise but a kind of immersion
you know in a framework of rules and uh
indeed i would argue a traditional set
of traditions and and you see this
everywhere um uh and uh because there's
one example mozart's another example i
mean do people really think that mozart
um was the sublime genius he was as it
were just because of some godlike
capacity they did at the time he
undoubtedly was an astonishing uh
processor and creative innovator but he
did so on the basis of materials what
were these materials well the works of
cpe bach the works of gluck the works of
uh
handle the works are preeminently of
haydn i mean you can see his work coming
out of that and in a funny way
uh you know even though beethoven in
some respects is seen as an even greater
innovator he in way is doing the same
thing
as well so
that the question is is that does that
mean there's no scope for genuine
radicalism and and the answer i think is
is no and what you see is in a way an
extension of what lisa described which
is the the actor creativity is lifting a
set of rules from one place and then
applying them somewhere else and the
great example there i used to teach the
philosophy of maths and a great example
of that would be someone like gauss and
the invention of
non-euclidean geometries so what does
gauss do gas asks himself the question
well i have this flat space geometry
that we get from the ancient greeks and
euclid but actually there's something
odd about this because one of the
key elements of it the so-called
parallel postulate has never been proved
what happens if we varied that what
would we get if we varied that and then
he discovers that we would get curved
space and then sets out the mathematics
of curves phase that's an incredibly
innovative and incredible
and thoughtful achievement and then of
course einstein then does the same thing
in physics and says well what would
happen if space itself not just its
mathematical description but say so
space itself were differently shaped and
you get the application of non-euclidean
geometries in
and there and therefore the extension of
the belief that space itself might be
curved and that in turn leads to
theories of gravity and and the like so
um i think it is possible to tell a
story which combines the sense of shock
and amazement we have when we see these
things for the first time and yet to fit
them into an intelligible uh tradition
of creative elaboration and
imaginative adventure
thank you very much and same question to
you sripali patel are we right to value
knowledge over creativity
well i think i need to preface this with
um two things one i'm not sure
how much of a debate we'll have because
i agree with jesse and i agree with lisa
you know
i don't think these are diametrically
opposite and secondly i i actually took
the approach of um defense as a creative
i i came in here ready to to have a bit
of a battle in a bit of a fight so i
prepared a defense and i'm thinking do i
just throw this out so my script is out
virtually completely
yeah i would agree that both knowledge
and creativity are intangible concepts
and not mutually exclusive
the act of creating itself generates
both tacits and explicit knowledge and
facilitates a bi-directional knowledge
exchange forgive the language that i use
i've just come out of something called
the ref in academia
the creative practice itself often
embraces a speculative design process
now i've embraced the term speculative
design but it very much goes back to
what jesse was saying which was about
the what-if principle this idea of
experimentation what if
which involves conceptualization
ideation experimentation testing
evaluation
critical reflection and often produces
an output whether it's film music dance
books clothes and even furniture and
houses so the outputs are immense but i
think what's important to note and and
this may prove an element of
conversation here is um that creative
outputs can generate um understanding
empathy and provoke emotion and action
um an action in the audience or user so
that idea of the emotional interplay
with creativity and what it provokes i
think is is really quite interesting so
when we talk about knowledge are we
talking about explicit codified
knowledge or tacit knowledge which is
intuitive
rooted in context and experience which
is often hard to communicate and often
resides in the mind of the practitioner
i would argue that codified knowledge
can be quantified and fed into data
research more easily than the
qualitative nature of tacit knowledge so
again another important note i i feel to
highlight here is that the function of
the lived experience in the creative
process and output is very important um
so the question of value
um i came up with lots of figures um we
we know in the uk that the lfs
are proposing to defund the arts
subjects by 50 in the uk
um and uh though that the proposal
recognized the cultural importance and
enrichment to the arts and society there
was a considerable absence of
acknowledgement that the creative
critical thinking innovation and
practice of creative disciplines fueled
one of the largest contributions to the
uk
gdp so 117 billion in 2018 equivalent to
306 million a day with an average sector
growth of 7.4 percent a year
these figures were generated by the dcms
in february 2020
um and those figures can be broken down
further with the cultural sector
contributing 32.3 billion to the economy
with the growth growth rate of 2.7
percent
um in the digital sector um 149 billion
7.7 percent of the uk economy with a
year on growth of 7.9 percent which
would be interesting to have a look at
for this year during the pandemic just
to see what that growth is
so
just to conclude i would ask similar to
my colleagues here
why are we positioning knowledge against
creativity and what purpose does it
serve to not acknowledge the implicit
relationship between creativity and
knowledge generation
thank you very much for paulie that's
really interesting i want to come back
to that in terms of our school
curriculum um
in a moment but i think first um
you know
i think all of you have this have
discussed and largely agreed on the
value of
of creativity so
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas